quand même gilbert bécaud décoré c'était
hier soir à la sacem la société des
auteurs compositeurs et éditeurs de
musique notre gibert nationale a reçu
une médaille de la francophonie des
mains de madame michaud chevry et les
200 millions de francophones étaient
représentés par un grand nombre
d'ambassadeurs gilbert bécaud considère
il l'a dit hier soir que la chanson
française se porte bien même à
l'étranger il doit d'ailleurs partir
pour melbourne et gérard dalmas était
présent lorsque lui a été remis l'ordre
de la pléiade
quand tu danses mademoiselle lisent ou
pardon madame lucette michaux chevry
secrétaire d'état à la francophonie
enchanté hier soir d'être en compagnie
d'hommes 600 mille volts survoltés par
sa nouvelle médaille
pour cette cérémonie organisée en
quelque sorte par 200 millions de
francophones quel meilleur d'accord que
la sacem la maison clé de sol
que de me trouver à côté de normes qui
symbolise pour moi teint de chaleur
temps de communication et mémos sione
profondément gilbert bécaud au nom du
président de l'association
internationale
des parlementaires de langue française
en présence de 41 ambassadeurs
francophones gilbert devient donc le 42e
celui de la chanson française de par le
monde près de 1000 chansons depuis 1953
il n'altéra bhl bécaud le dernier des
trois b après brel et brassens
je suis pas un fanatique des honneurs
mais je suis content que que l'on puisse
voyager prendre beaucoup d'avions
prendre beaucoup de trains prendre
beaucoup de voitures pour nous beaucoup
de choses comme ça et qu'un jour on
s'aperçoive alors je sais que sur place
ils s'en aperçoit avec l'ensemble soit
au courant ça fait toujours plaisir mais
vous savez la plus immédiat et que j'ai
c'est le samedi soir là puis avec les
balcons de booth à ces formules ça c'est
une très belle médaille
sur volane
si la valeur
dans ce non
je sais pas
si la balade
tiens
monsieur gilbert boulet vue ils dansent
pas mal avec